poi soprattutto i pippo oggi siamo
tornati su rocket league con lo stesso
né nazionale o harry sembra riunione
quando urla harry ogni ogni harry potter
hermione aspetta che è difficile per
loro parla
no io veramente veramente quale che ci
sono ma lui lo stivato saltando si è
girato sgommando e mi ha comunque ben
fatto e più fastidioso di poti puo
esistere praticamente no ma ho fatto
come pazzesche guardali ma ci credo che
ok l'ho tolta
mi sono tolto perché la sta valutando
fuori abbiamo fatto le cose pazzesche
finora venire tranne questa che è una
cagata attenzione bravissimo vano perché
io li al gol non lo so fare così prendo
solo i pali
mannaggia turbo riesce ma che partita
sul bene mamma mia
sì perché corrono tanto anche l'oro che
si va da una parte all'altra gioca 15
gol perché io sono meglio di bastoni
porto
non ho capito niente neanche io ma fa
niente gol va bene ciao a casa ti ho
visto l'inter l'ho rubata faticose no no
io che ero bebè lasciata ok annuale
perché ho visto che avevo il controllo
così così ha detto meglio che la lascia
lui che è dritto dritto non male perché
ha fatto sta roba
ho provato
adesso me ne vado aiuto che bello che
era però si fosse uscito ci siamo
emozionati anche questa
hai visto con l'aiuto ad anello quello
bello quello che volevo con la
incredibile quello e lo riferisce bello
che questo mio a complimenti per
guardare protezione è il male oro colato
george weasley maestà non sa parlare
coppi in mezzo ecco la tira tutto il
mondo gol singolo reveal è lui a lui
perché la mia vita è la cosa più brutta
che il mister ha veramente brussi
annuncio vada vada vada vado vado in un
cincischia contro george weasley
demolito ma la palla buona per noi
attenzione hanno fatto io non li capisco
se due giocando adesso ne anch'io perché
mi hanno fregato bravo con il 99 veleno
vera 20 la tiratina di latina
io lo farò rilasciata per fare il figo
niente all'iva nardò e riteneva al è
stato letto anche un po anche un po
trovato sul finale trai harding
dell'altra della rovesciata ma
l'importante è vincere
non so cosa è successo di wii che
arrivano in porta forse è gol
la mia azione abbiamo fatto ma come
siamo noi ha detto voglio crederlo bello
mentre ma c'è mai fatto bene che azione
abbia sì sì e la toglieva tra l'altro
hai fatto bene mi sentivo bellissima
azione
questa è una nazione dolcetti vai
eccola no dai subito cattivi però se
momento perché sennò poi si pigliano che
vai
ok prova a partire da oggi
bene l'ovale per niente anzi ma che
azione ma che so io che siamo ma
bravissimi tutto giusto è proprio il
pressing è giusto dai tagli e dai e dai
ala con lo segue lo vedo ok quando turbo
nella tolta prova vedersi assoluta là
dentro stesso è rischiata dove stava
panica e così si va a qualcuno non va
nessuno
ok vai di partita giocato legge facendo
pressing e attenzione così non mi piace
la palla sta lì out no no di kalinka la
nuova tuta o prenderla proprio in croce
perfetto mai nel mondo è ma abbiamo
sbagliato perché non siamo mai ripartiti
e prima o poi a palaia sì sì sì sì sì
cagliari partenza no state lavo dei tir
o l'anti perfetto palo in fuori a
capitolino top coat lai
[Applauso]
bravo però attenzione ma mi sa che fanno
questi aveva mandato sul palo
ok era tutto programmato
no se la toccavo cerca di tornare io li
faccio perde tempo
si ok nostri ingarbugliato da solo per
fortuna e meno male
io tutto il turbo vai non ha più 271
contro 11 aprile ma lo faccio un grosso
è manifesto dare il giusto tributo ok ci
credo dell'ancora io ci credo traversa
mamma mia mi sono preso vabbè dai
ragazzi pazzesco nice dai ce la
meritavamo noi giusto così tacchio tra
uno die ancora attenzione che possono
far di kick off
quindi diciamo anche coppie diamo in due
ecco un gol di kiko mare e alle
seychelles altri 3 a 1 32 un secondo che
pensa che vivere davvero colpi la palla
e se stesso calcolato dell'avviamento
perché ora che il tipo di armi sai che
sai che se non finiva lì era gol perché
il tipo era partito io non ero partito
deciso ragazzi video si compone questa
revisione situazioni servizi costieri
perché non mi piaceva savino una bella
ragazza
[Musica]